The joe rogan experience.
He's very strong on the ground,
which is one of the reasons why it was
so impressive that he took his back and
choked him like that.
Yeah,
I mean I think I have a different style
than,
than uh,
a lot of people can see,
you know,
you,
you go back to [inaudible] and all this,
like his style is,
it's good.
It's obviously very good,
but I can see a lot of holes in it.
And I saw those holes many years ago.
I've been called how big could beat for
years I've been wanting to fight them
just because people got those questions.
I've got those questions too.
So I'm like,
let's see what this mother fucker got.
Like,
cause I see it,
I see them hoes,
you know,
I don't really focus on too much of the
good.
I'm like,
what holes?
I got that boy number.
No telly you.
What are the holes?
What do you see it,
you know,
even on some of his take on a lot of his
takedowns,
he,
he misses a lot of them.
You know,
he's very square.
He kinda just bum rushes.
You know,
people were talking about the Barboza
fight before and they're like,
are you looking at that fighter and
you're going to try and build off that
when I'm like,
yeah,
I mean he did.
Okay.
The fight was good.
He beat the hell out of Barboza,
but I saw the holes in it.
You know,
he's just running square forward.
Adam,
you know,
he's,
he got hit with a lot of shots.
I didn't see it for,
for people in the outside watching him
because the way he just came forward on
Barboza was like,
he was indestructible.
I mean just,
it didn't matter.
I'm just going to get you,
it's just a matter of time.
Keep throwing your kicks.
I'm going to get you.
I got you.
You got those guys.
But the body gives up.
You know,
you got Justin Gait,
she has the same way the body will give
up and the rest of it,
hey,
I just felt like shaky and just weird.
And then I realized,
oh,
this is like a,
almost like a cocaine type thing.
Like,
do you know why we have wider cane
because of cocaine or,
yeah,
that's a guy named William Stewart
Halston who was uh,
so near and dear to my heart because he
was the original,
he was the founding surgeon at Johns
Hopkins and one of the original four
horsemen.
So the four main physicians that
basically have shaped medicine in this
country all started out at Hopkins.
Uh Oh,
slur in medicine,
Hopkins in surgery and two other guys,
Walsh.
And I'm blanking on the,
Kelly was the third one.
Um,
and he basically figured out,
cause you got to remember like there was
a day when surgery was staggeringly
barbaric.
Like prior to ether surgery was like,
all right,
can you hold him down?
Like gag,
um,
get them drunk,
gag him and like we're going to do our
thing.
It's fucking crazy.
So God,
I used to know all of this shit.
I don't remember any of the exact dates
anymore,
but it was like kind of like mid 18
hundreds to late 18 hundreds when up at
Massachusetts General Hospital.
I forget the name of who it was,
but someone basically came up with
ether.
So ether became the first form of
anesthetic.
But you know,
you were sort of knocking people out.
Well it was,
you know,
fast forward probably 20,
30 years when Halstad figured out that
this thing called cocaine could provide
local anesthetic.
So he began experimenting with like
crazy and of course in the process
became like patently addicted to it.
So you have this entire generation of
surgeons at Hopkins from that early era
that were completely coke addicted,
so halstead and all of his first
generation of residents.
Um,
and then of course from that we got
Lidacain,
Bupivacaine,
all of these things that don't have the
same properties.
But to this day,
cocaine is still used and,
and most people don't realize it,
but cocaine's a schedule two drug
meaning it actually has a medical
application.
I'm like heroin,
which has scheduled one and the dea and
marijuana.
That's right.
Today both you and I have produced
cancer cells in all buddy.
What prevents those kinds of cells from
becoming the disease that we call cancer
is impart these natural killer cells and
after one night of four as of sleep,
that is a remarkable state of immune
deficiency and that's one of the reasons
why insufficient sleep predicts cancer.
Wow.
I could also speak about your
cardiovascular system and all it takes
is one hour because there is a global
experiment that's performed on 1.6
billion people across 70 countries twice
a year,
and it's called daylight savings time.
Now in the spring when we lose an hour
of sleep,
we see a subsequent 24% increase in
heart attacks.
What?
In the fall and the autumn,
when we gain an hour sleep,
there's a 21% decrease in heart attacks.
So it's bi-directional.
That's how fragile and vulnerable your
body is to even just the smallest
perturbation of sleep.
One hour is,
yeah.
Wow.
That is,
you're blowing my fucking mind.
It's frightening.
I mean,
you can go even further by the way,
you know?
Wow.
Insufficient sleep will even erode the
very fabric of biological life itself,
your DNA code.
So in one study they took a group of
healthy adults and they limited them to
six hours of sleep for one week and they
compared the profile of gene activity
relative to when those same people were
getting eight hours of sleep and there
were two critical results.
The first was that a sizable 711 genes
were distorted in their activity caused
by one week of six hours of sleep,
which is highly relevant by the way,
because we know that many people are
trying to survive on six hours of sleep
during the week.
Wow.
The second,
sorry.
No,
please go.
I was going to say the second sort of
perhaps more interesting result was that
about half of those genes were actually
increasing their activity.
The other half were actually suppressed.
Those genes that were switched off by
six hours of sleep for one week with
genes related to your immune response,
many of them,
so you become immune deficient.
Those genes that were increased or what
we call overexpressed were genes that
were related to the promotion of tumors,
genes that were related to longterm
chronic inflammation within the body and
genes that were associated with stress.
And as a consequence,
cardiovascular disease.
The,
I would say the most efficient hundred
miler I've done is,
uh,
when I,
I ran 11 hours and 40 minutes,
55 seconds at a race in 2015 called Holy
Shit.
You Ran,
you ran a hundred miles in 11 hours.
Yeah.
That was,
that was on a trip.
That was one on the track in the SPEC of
a fuck.
That's crazy.
Ran 11 hours.
You were at a hundred miles.
Yeah.
So I think the thing that,
how long does it take to drive a hundred
miles?
Okay.
Takes it,
I mean,
if you go a hundred miles an hour,
it takes an hour or longer to get to the
airport.
If the traffic on the phone,
how's Zach that are broke?
The US 100 mile record.
You averaged seven fucking minutes per
mile for almost 12 hours.
Dude,
that is insane.
That is fucking insane.
Bert Kreischer.
He brags when he runs seven minute miles
for like three miles.
What is burdened up running that the La
Marathon in six and a half,
six and a half.
I think it was shorter than that.
I think it was five,
five or something.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Ours Dad.
Yeah,
he's fucking JV triggers.
Well,
I'll say,
I'll say this here,
bird,
if you're listening,
contact me.
I'll get you to four and a half in six
months.
You write up your challenge.
Zach fucking man,
if he tells you can do it too.
That is,
that is an incredible number that you
broke the u s 100 mile record by running
seven fucking minutes per mile.
It's,
it's,
it's crazy.
I talk about something and I don't type
it in.
I don't write a message.
I don't write an email and I'll see an
ad.
So it's fine on us all the time.
That doesn't happen to you.
I,
it hasn't happened to me,
but it's happened to enough people that
I believe you.
It's insane.
Well,
I believe you know what?
No matter what,
but really crazy.
I've talked to so many people that have
had that happen.
Somebody sent me a tweet yesterday that
said they were listening to a podcast
that we were doing.
We were talking about something and then
that's something appeared in their
Google ads and he's like,
I never looked up this.
And oh no.
It wasn't a google ad.
It was a youtube search.
It was a youtube suggested.
He's like my fucking computers
listening.
Yep.
Cuter.
And what APP is doing this?
I mean,
I'm about to just go to a flip phone
because I don't want to,
it's,
it's bullshit.
We know that youtube audio is being
listened to because they're mining it to
for ad ad stuff already.
It's not even real.
It's not a spy thing that's just out
there.
That's how they do it.
Right,
but is that if you're playing things?
Yeah,
so when we're playing,
so if he's playing a podcasts on
Youtube,
youtube,
listening to that and that's how they
suggest it's just happening in their
ads.
What I think might be happening with
people are noticing now is not just that
it's happening within the software.
It's that your actual device,
the microphone is on and the laptop
camera on.
Some people block the camera with tape.
They're not blocking the microphone.
Exactly.
How the hell do you block the
microphone?
You don't even know where it is.
How do I,
how can we have like some sort of
tutorial about like how we can prevent
all of our shit from being collected?
Like that whole,
the facebook,
Cambridge analytica thing.
I feel like everyone missed the boat of
what that
story was.
You heard about that right?
At the Cambridge Analytica.
They're data mining all your shit.
It's like,
yeah,
if you're on facebook,
everything's being taken in data mind
that's very obvious,
but what wasn't really investigated,
I think channel four did this crazy
investigation where they pretended like
they were a patron trying to hire
Cambridge Analytica,
some billionaire dude and they put them
on camera.
It's all recorded.
The guys are basically like,
it's basically like a private
intelligence from almost like a black
water where you can hire mercenaries to
set up honeypots with prostitutes,
take down politicians,
spy on them.
They set up shell companies with mis
six,
um,
massaad um,
it's all just untraceable shit.
They just go stout.
They said they can ghost in out of
countries.
They literally said that they stage the
entire Kenyan election.
They were like,
we staged the whole thing.
We wrote all the speeches.
Yeah.
Ken,
this,
yeah.
This is,
this is backed by a billionaire.
Robert Mercer,
the same guy who can behind channel four
did a crazy investigation about it.
[inaudible].